jerry is an Iowa hi Jerry how are you
yeah so I got a comment a question
coming is that my wife and I we were
really not scared at all we are we're
taking this seriously
but we really do have a lot of peace in
Jesus one of the few shows you can say
that on the air right man different
extra sleep and doing the elliptical
reading books and not chilling good for
me it's a good excuse to recharge and we
are saying people to uh with encouraging
words but are like church bells in my
wife and others we got this percolating
question going and so in one corner we
have the black couple Bible verses Psalm
37 21 even an evil man borrows doesn't
pay back and the proverb I can't tell
the verse I'm kind of nervous
a good man leaves and inheritance to his
children's children so that's in one one
verse or one corner and then in the
other corner we've got our American duty
to spend government free money checks on
the way and so I've got this planet I've
kind of cooked up with through
consulting the people and my plan is to
calculate and accepts a rebate part for
the taxes we've paid for these checks on
the way but the stimulus part I want to
send it back and this is crazy
with a note that instructs the
government to put it on the national
debt as if anyone cares but I do want to
pay some percentage for the military and
border security so don't just want veero
taxes so the my question is I've asked
people and no one can tell me or will
tell me and I can to find out is all
these checks coming to us are they going
to go on the national debt as if
I feel it's really tomorrow and I just
don't I just don't want any part of it
but on the other hand you know of course
is gone yeah there's not any money in
Washington of course it's connections
that they already spent more than they
make than they have coming in that's
what a deficit is and when you add to
the deficit there's only one way to
finance that and that's national debt so
of course we're getting ready to borrow
about another trillion dollars up there
for these various stimulus packages so
that Washington you know tells you they
did something that they love you and
they're that they're your great provider
although I doubt a thousand dollars is
going to change anybody's life as a
matter of fact I'm sure it isn't so and
while or is the biblical part of it goes
there's a construct in the book the
legacy journey I'll send you a copy of
it so you can read the whole thing
because you're intrigued by this right
now and it's a good place you are in
your life the construct in scripture is
very clear I call it now then us/them
now is take care of your own household
first or you're worse than unbeliever so
your job is to take care of your family
biblically before you do anything else
US is take care now then you take care
of then now then us then now then you
take care of your future you say for
your kids college and retirement in the
house of the wise our stores of choice
food and oil now then us is your
extended family and that's leaving an
inheritance to a children's children
where you start talking about helping
others outside of your extended family
and them is when you start helping the
entire community outside so in other
words if you get a stimulus check or you
get a check from anywhere and there's
not food on your table but you send it
back for some social good you are out of
order biblically biblically you should
have taken care of your family first and
that's all through Scripture it's a very
clear construct in there but it's it the
that's putting the scriptures in a
connected way that allows you now then
us/them I'll send you the legacy journey
book hold on Zach we'll pick
don't give it to you as a gift give you
something else to read while you're in
your 14-day sabbatical here